Lucia: 这也是牛奶那个
Lucia: This one is also milk.
Jake:我靠这已经是汤了
Jake: Oh my, this has turned into soup.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:这冰淇淋
Jake: This ice cream...
Jake:这麦旋风
Jake: This McFlurry...
Jake:已经是汤了
Jake: It's already soup.
Jake:有用吗那就动一下
Jake: Is it useful? Then move it a bit.
其他人:有有有
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:你放下边
Alice: Put it down here.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: What the...
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 哈哈没事
Shure: Haha, it's fine.
Jake:自取灭亡
Jake: Self-destruction.
Shure: 高蛋白
Shure: High protein.
Jake:给给您吃哈哈
Jake: Here, have a bite, haha.
Shure: 哇谁这么奢侈
Shure: Wow, who's so extravagant?
Shure: 点的安格斯候牛榜
Shure: Ordered the Angus beef burger.
Shure: 这我靠
Shure: This is crazy.
Tasha: 之前说吃安格斯厚牛堡的都是渣女
Tasha: They say girls who eat Angus beef burgers are trashy.
Tasha: 你是捞女是吧是吗
Tasha: Are you a gold digger? Huh?
其他人：对对对
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Tasha: 有那个梗是吗
其他人：对对对
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人：男朋友我想吃阿根特牛堡
Tasha: 你个捞米
Tasha: You gold digger.
其他人：你个捞米
Others: You gold digger.
其他人：不能吃便宜的吗
Others: Can't you eat something cheaper?
其他人：搞这么贵这么物质啊
Others: Why so expensive and materialistic?
Jake:盲盒盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind boxes, blind boxes.
Jake:还有谁没挑吗
Jake: Anyone who hasn't picked yet?
Lucia: 乱拆
Lucia: Randomly open it.
Jake:谁有派吗
Jake: Does anyone have a pie?
Jake:派是怎么点的
Jake: How do you order pies?
Tasha: 派是我点
Tasha: I ordered the pie.
Tasha: 我点了两个派
Tasha: I ordered two pies.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 给你一个
Tasha: Here, one for you.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:薯条薯条都是谁
Jake: Who are the fries for?
Jake:薯条就分着吃吧
Jake: Let's share the fries.
Jake:但是没有地方放呢
Jake: But there's no place to put them.
Jake:要不然
Jake: Or...
Jake:怎么找不到啊
Jake: Why can't I find it?
Jake:哈哈哈呃OK
Jake: Hahaha, uh, OK.
Lucia: 把这一挪
Lucia: Move this over.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:哎呀呀呀
Jake: Oh no, oh no.
Jake:好损失了8根
Jake: We've lost 8 fries.
Lucia: 对不起对不起
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Jake:麦当劳汉堡
Jake: McDonald's burger.
Jake:麦当劳薯条
Jake: McDonald's fries.
Jake:薯条是叫什么呀这叫
Jake: What's the name for these fries?
Jake:薯条自由是吗
Jake: Is it called "Fries Freedom"?
Tasha: 今天晚上怎么吃这么好
Tasha: Why are we eating so well tonight?
Tasha: 我们是要走路了吗
Tasha: Are we going for a walk later?
Katrina: 牛排
Katrina: Steak.
Tasha: 要上路了是吧
Tasha: We're heading out, right?
Tasha: 我说今天晚上怎么吃这么好吃
Tasha: I mean, why are we eating so well tonight?
Tasha: 要上路了
Tasha: We're heading out.
Katrina: 还有的堡呢
Katrina: There's still some burgers left.
Jake:呃还还有很多
Jake: Uh, there's still a lot.
Jake:也没有很多了
Jake: Or not that many.
Jake:还有几个
Jake: Just a few.
Alice:恩
Lucia: 我想你是直接挤在上面的
Lucia: I thought you were squeezing it on top.
Lucia: 我以为是挤在旁边然后站的那种
Lucia: I thought you were squeezing it to the side and standing.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 没事都行
Lucia: It's fine either way.
Lucia: 无所谓了
Lucia: Doesn't matter.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
其他人:这个能吃了吗
Others: Can we eat this now?
Tasha: 不给吃我们要摆盘呢
Tasha: No, we need to plate it first.
Tasha: OK OK杨老师
Tasha: OK OK, Mr. Yang.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 嗯你能把桌子收一下
Tasha: Hmm, can you clear the table?
Tasha: 把外面的所有台位吗
Tasha: All the tables outside?
Tasha: 你能摆一下吗
Tasha: Can you set them up?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 还有一盒薯条
Katrina: And another box of fries.
Lucia: 居然这么多薯条
Lucia: So many fries!
Alice:薯条开会
Alice: Fries meeting!
Katrina: 哈哈薯条山
Katrina: Haha, a mountain of fries!
其他人:卧槽
Others: Whoa!
Alice:太搞笑了
Alice: This is hilarious.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:还有3个
Jake: There are 3 more.
Jake:宝是谁的
Jake: Whose is this?
Jake:有一个是我的可能吧
Jake: One of them might be mine.
Jake:这个可以开
Jake: This one can be opened.
Shure: 要开个会
Shure: We need to have a meeting.
其他人:我靠我草
Others: Oh my god.
其他人:感动死我了
Others: I'm so touched.
Jake:我开了我开了
Jake: I'll open it, I'll open it.
其他人:呃开会
Others: Uh, a meeting.
其他人:他刚让我妈拆开一个bug
Others: He just asked my mom to fix a bug.
其他人:他要他来一个我写bug
Others: He needs to write a bug.
其他人:哎怎么这么多厚牛堡
Others: Why are there so many thick burgers?
Jake:盲盒盲盒
Jake: Blind boxes, blind boxes.
Lucia: 哎不好意思
Lucia: Oh, sorry.
其他人:你想想你当时点的那个
Others: Think about what you ordered.
其他人:我点的我点的应该是培根
Others: I ordered, I think it was bacon.
其他人:啊培根
Others: Ah, bacon.
其他人:那可能我给你吃了
Others: Maybe I ate yours.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
其他人:但我记得我点的培根
Others: But I remember ordering bacon.
其他人:怎么还开火了
Others: Why is there still a fire?
嗯
Hmm.
Jake:什么牛排
Jake: What steak is it?
其他人:牛排是不是刘太监的
Others: Is that steak for Liu the Eunuch?
其他人:哦我想起来我菜的菜
Others: Oh, I remember my dish.
其他人:不好意思
Others: Sorry.
其他人： 烧水稍微有点
Others: The water is a bit hot.
Jake:我我我我看看怎么收拾
Jake: I-I-I'll see how to clean this up.
其他人：通过你的每条左手
Others: Through your left hand.
Jake:这个怎么收掉
Jake: How do I clean this up?
Tasha: 还有一块谁来认领一下
Tasha: There's still a piece left, who wants to claim it?
Jake:放牛排里吧
Jake: Put it in the steak.
其他人：之前我在上海吃
Others: I used to eat in Shanghai.
其他人：：街头那傻屌地方
Others: On that dumb street.
其他人：不是有那个中国总部吗
Others: Isn't that where the China HQ is?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
其他人：但就是蛮好的
Others: But it was pretty good.
其他人：有段时间吃吐了
Others: I ate until I threw up for a while.
其他人：一点都不想吃
Others: I don't want to eat it at all.
Jake:是这种吗
Jake: Is it this kind?
其他人：是
Others: Yeah.
Jake:一样的
Jake: It's the same.
其他人：他说
Others: He said
其他人：汉堡的这个是你的
Others: This burger is yours.
其他人：还不是他不刷才一起吃的吗
Others: Isn't it because he didn't clean up that we ate together?
Jake:这个丢掉哈丢掉吧
Jake: Throw this away, just throw it away.
Tasha: 丢掉
Tasha: Throw it away.
其他人：丢那了
Others: Throw it there.
Tasha: 这你刚吃的芒果菠萝是吗
Tasha: Is that the mango pineapple you just ate?
Jake:这有差别吗
Jake: Does it make a difference?
Alice:哎呦我去
Alice: Oh my gosh.
其他人:今天中午吃汉堡晚上吃麦当劳
Others: Ate burgers for lunch, McDonald's for dinner.
Alice:还有垃圾吗
Alice: Any more trash?
Jake:垃圾袋这有垃圾袋
Jake: Trash bags, there are trash bags here.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
这我的还没吃完呢
Others: I haven't finished mine yet.
Alice:蛋清
Alice: Egg whites.
Jake:大伙了大伙了
Jake: Everyone, everyone.
Alice:蛋黄打打进那里面了
Alice: The yolk, beat the yolk into it.
Jake:三个酱
Jake: Three sauces.
Alice:你在欣赏自己的作品吗
Alice: Are you admiring your own work?
其他人：没有我在看他熟没熟
其他人：感觉不一样
Others: Feels different.
Alice:无妨一分熟也是熟
Jake:我把酱开了
Jake: I opened the sauce.
其他人：那个帮我拿两个
Others: Can you get me two of those?
其他人:吃麦当劳为什么不需要蘸酱
Others: Why don't you need sauce for McDonald's?
其他人：就我自己
Others: Just for myself.
Lucia: 粘
Lucia: Sticky.
Alice:无妨
Alice: No worries.
Alice:我拿着吧
Alice: I'll hold it.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
其他人：那拿那个盘子
Others: Then take that plate.
其他人:我说话没有精盐味
Others: My words lack saltiness.
其他人:味道不纯
Others: The flavor isn't pure.
其他人:但
Others: But
其他人:我确实很好的融入了北京的社会环境
Others: I really fit well into Beijing's social environment.
Alice:啊没没弄到你吧
Alice: Oh, I didn't get it on you, did I?
Jake:热爱挤地铁
Jake: Love squeezing onto the subway.
其他人:不热爱挤地铁
Others: Not loving the crowded subway.
其他人:真的
Others: Really.
其他人:我在北京上海实习之后我喜欢上海
Others: After interning in both Beijing and Shanghai, I prefer Shanghai.
其他人:最重要一点就是
Others: The most important thing is
其他人:因为我在上海打车便宜
Others: It's cheaper to take a cab in Shanghai.
其他人:因为上海最省
Others: Shanghai is the most economical.
Alice:基本全熟吧
Alice: It's basically well-done.
Alice:哈哈哈哎
Alice: Hahaha, hey.
其他人：你这个时候应该给你
Others: You should get some for yourself now.
其他人：哎给他找点盐
Others: Hey, get him some salt.
其他人：对我还没放
其他人：不不你刚就就这样
Others: No, no, just like this.
其他人：就这样
Others: Just like this.
其他人：关节炎是吧
Others: Is it arthritis?
其他人：撒盐哥那个撒法
Others: Like Salt Bae's style.
其他人：你这样撒
Others: Do it like this.
其他人：你这样把那个手腕能怎么激情
Others: How can you get excited with that wrist?
其他人：怎么激情
Others: Get excited.
其他人：然后给你拍一下那个
Others: Then I'll take a shot of that.
其他人：再说那个撒法
Others: Talk about the style.
其他人：忘了我的盐放到哪
Others: I forgot where I put my salt.
Alice:那不是哎
Alice: Isn't that it?
Alice:那不是吗
Alice: Isn't it?
Alice:那不是盐吗
Alice: Isn't that salt?
Alice:那个那个
Alice: That one, that one.
其他人：这个嗯没有没有
Others: No, no.
其他人：  刚才有一小
Others: There was a little bit earlier.
其他人：因为我已经加过了
Others: Because I've already added it.
Katrina: 用那个湿纸巾擦一擦
Katrina: Wipe it with a wet tissue.
Alice:哈哈等一下拍你你要摆一下吗
Alice: Haha, wait, do you want to pose for the shot?
Lucia: 可以用这个吗
Lucia: 不能只能用那那个那种纸吗
Lucia: Can't we just use that kind of paper?
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Katrina: 或者餐巾纸加水也行
Katrina: Or we can use napkins with water too.
Alice:笑死我了
Alice: You're killing me!
Jake:撒一个撒一个
Jake: Sprinkle a bit.
Jake:撒着了你
Jake: You sprinkled it.
Lucia: 要不拿那个
Lucia: Or use that.
Jake:还没
Jake: Not yet.
Lucia: 拿这个加水好了
Lucia: Use this and add water.
Jake:撒呢
Jake: Sprinkle it.
Alice:撒过了
Alice: It's sprinkled.
Lucia: 哎呦sorry
Lucia: Oh sorry.
Lucia: 蘸一点蘸一点
Lucia: Dab a little, dab a little.
其他人:这个这个直接装盘吗
Others: Do we just put this directly on the plate?
Lucia: 哇看起来好好吃
Lucia: Wow, it looks so good.
Lucia: 如果我们害怕他太腥了的话
Lucia: If we're worried it's too fishy,
Lucia: 也是不是可以给底下铺一层那个
Lucia: can't we put a layer of that at the bottom?
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 那个那个叫什么
Lucia: What's that called...
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 油纸还是烘焙纸那种纸
Lucia: Parchment paper or baking paper.
Lucia: 因为感觉这个刚拆开的话
Lucia: Because it feels like when you just open it,
Lucia: 不知道它有一些味什么的
Lucia: you don't know what kind of smell it has.
Alice:哈
Alice: Huh?
Lucia: 散散散完了没有
Lucia: Is it all sprinkled?
Lucia: 对要不就扑一个
Lucia: Yeah, otherwise just put a layer.
Lucia: 那个对在最底下有
Lucia: Yeah, at the very bottom.
Alice:铺一下那个油纸吧
Alice: Lay some parchment paper.
Alice:我拿一下在这里吧我记得
Alice: I'll get it, it's over here I think.
Katrina:  这是在为明天做准备吗
Katrina: Is this for tomorrow's preparation?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: Probably.
Alice:怎么这么烂
Alice: Why is it so bad?
Lucia: 对他这个是有一点颜色
Lucia: Yeah, this one has some color.
Lucia: 还会如果用水一擦还会掉一些
Lucia: If you wipe it with water, some will come off.
Jake:抬得越高越好
Jake: The higher you raise it, the better.
Alice:铺吗
Alice: Should I lay it?
Alice:那我搁那了
Alice: I'll put it there then.
Jake:在这上面
Jake: On top of here.
Jake:然后开始上菜
Jake: Then start serving.
其他人:真的刘帅
Others: Really, Choiszt.
其他人:我要是女生我嫁
Other: If I were a girl, I'd marry him.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:河鸡
Jake: Frog chicken.
Alice:可以直接捏吗
Alice: Can I just squeeze it directly?
其他人：不可能
Other: Impossible.
Jake:嗯好吃
Jake: Mmm, delicious.
其他人：以后千万不要联系我
Other: Never contact me again in the future.
Jake:这个可以这个可以
Jake: This one works, this one works.
其他人： 啊
Other: Ah.
其他人:凑巧做做成了一次
Other: By chance, it worked once.
其他人:有没有非常的谦虚啊
Other: Isn't he very humble?
其他人:如果我是一个女生
Other: If I were a girl,
其他人:我就非常喜欢谦虚的男人
Other: I would really like humble men.
其他人:哈哈哈哈
Other: Hahahaha
Katrina: 你的掩盖不了你爱上他的事实
Katrina: You can't hide the fact that you love him.
其他人:我自从有一次点了麦当劳的牛奶
Other: Ever since I ordered McDonald's milk once,
其他人:麦当劳的牛奶非常的牛
Other: McDonald's milk is really good.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia: 这渣怎么掉不出来啊
Lucia: Why can't this residue come out?
Jake:扎木头扎
Jake: Use a wooden stick.
Lucia: 没有就是拿拿厨房纸擦一下的话
Lucia: No, if you use kitchen paper to wipe it,
Lucia: 厨房纸会掉
Lucia: the paper will break.
Lucia: 一些小渣
Lucia: Into small pieces.
Lucia: 这里面也铺那个啥算了
Lucia: Maybe we should put some baking paper inside.
Lucia: 也铺那个油纸算
Lucia: Put some baking paper inside.
其他人：刘帅啥时候跟女朋友分手呵呵呵
Other: When did Choiszt break up with his girlfriend? Hehehe
Tasha: 好恶毒
Tasha: So vicious.
其他人：哈哈哈时间管理大师
Other: Hahaha, master of time management.
Alice:给薇薇留一个
Alice: Save one for Tasha.
Alice:给薇薇
Alice:哎没纸了
Alice: Hey, we're out of paper.
Jake:今天还要做几道几道甜点
Jake: How many more desserts are we making today?
Jake:快完成的3道
Jake: Almost done with three.
其他人：他眼睛没电了
Other: His eyes are out of energy.
其他人：师傅
Other: Master.
Jake:优秀员工
Jake: Excellent employee.
Jake:这就是一路在记录
Jake: This is all being recorded.
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Jake:还会啊
Jake: Still here?
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Jake:怕怕外边的人挺麻烦
Jake: I'm afraid dealing with outsiders is quite troublesome.
Alice:什么
其他人：门票
Others: Tickets.
Jake:看看能不能把这几天本给回
Jake: Let's see if we can recover the cost over these few days.
其他人:我跟你讲
Others: Let me tell you.
其他人:你去海淀黄庄门口
Others: You go to the entrance of Haidian Huangzhuang.
其他人：将来可以给你孩子说
Others: You can tell your kids in the future.
Jake:海淀黄庄
Jake: Haidian Huangzhuang.
其他人：这家伙带着你来蹦
Others: This guy is taking you to jump.
Jake:我靠我靠
Jake: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
其他人：哎你说他们
Others: Hey, do you think they...
其他人：谁说 1,000多个人
Others: Who said there are over a thousand people?
Jake:不是你组个名字就一天开玩笑
Jake: No, you form a name, and then joke around all day.
其他人：什么什么可以数
Others: What, what can be counted?
其他人：真真有可能
Others: It really is possible.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
其他人：还有一天了
Others: There's still one day left.
其他人：在地铁门口找一个带着小孩的家长
Others: Find a parent with a kid at the subway entrance.
其他人： ：要不要来参加我们的
Others: Ask them: Do you want to join us?
Alice:你来你的孩子
Alice: You come with your kid.
其他人:你的孩子
Others: Your kid.
其他人:将来有可能会出现在我们的论文里面
Others: Your kid might appear in our future papers.
其他人:我们是做AI的
Others: We're working on AI.
其他人:你知道我们女子今年开始的高峰赛道
Others: You know our girls' high-peak track started this year.
其他人::你不想想你的孩子不能输在起跑
Others: Don't you want your kid to have a good start?
其他人:孩子升到初中正好结婚
Others: When your kid enters middle school, it's just the right time.
其他人:是开初中赛道了
Others: The middle school track is open.
其他人:对
Others: Yeah.
Lucia: 呦对不起对不起
Lucia: Oh, sorry, sorry.
其他人:海淀皇上那味可抽
Others: Haidian Emperor's taste is strong.
其他人:我操我知道海淀皇上初中
Others: Damn, I know Haidian Emperor's middle school.
其他人:哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Alice:妈呀还薯条泛滥了
Alice: Oh my, fries are everywhere.
其他人:那你不是在海淀皇上捡生捡死吗
Others: Aren't you picking up life and death at Haidian Emperor?
其他人:我感觉
Others: I feel...
其他人:我感觉你应该不属于那种极度激娃的
Others: I feel like you shouldn't be one of those extreme parents.
其他人:真的吗
Others: Really?
其他人:还有我身边的人都是小学
Others: And everyone around me is still in elementary school.
Katrina: 这好可爱
Katrina: This is so cute.
其他人:初中什么上课的班的人
Others: What class do the junior high students attend?
Katrina: 比那个比那个网图要好看哎
Katrina: It looks better than the pictures online.
其他人:都是都带海带王装啊
Others: They all wear the Seaweed King outfit.
其他人:都带海带王装吗
Others: Do they all wear the Seaweed King outfit?
其他人:对这都是什么人大富人我
Others: Yeah, who are these rich people?
Katrina: 还有一个大的尾巴
Katrina: And there's a big tail too.
其他人:感觉我跟他们人大富人接触一下
Others: I feel like I'm interacting with rich people.
其他人:他们人大富人确实挺厉害的
Others: These rich people are really impressive.
很Katrina:  可爱
Katrina: So cute.
其他人:哎你
Others: Hey, you...
其他人:你身上有有人大富人吗
Others: Do you have any rich people on you?
Katrina: 不这是我自己的
Katrina: No, this is mine.
Alice:我可以看一下吗
Alice: Can I take a look?
Katrina: 抱着这是我
Katrina: Hugging this, it's mine.
Katrina: 公费买的
Katrina: I bought it with public funds.
Alice:这是狐狸吗
Alice: Is this a fox?
Katrina:  对公费吗
Katrina: Yes, with public funds.
其他人：你跟他说
Others: Tell him.
其他人：：这个也太可爱了吧
Others: This is just too cute.
其他人：我一定要嫁给这个
Others: I must marry this.
其他人：：第一个送给我自己看的人
Others: The first person to show it to me.
Alice:谢谢好可爱
Alice: Thanks, it's so cute.
其他人:对
Others: Yeah.
其他人:非常的非常的夸张
Others: Very, very exaggerated.
其他人:我之前是参加此期实践的时候认识的
Others: I met them during this practical session.
其他人:当时我也能打
Others: Back then, I could also fight.
其他人:所以名县人越多越好
Others: So the more people from Ming County, the better.
其他人:你
Others: You...
其他人: 女朋友啊
Others: Girlfriend, huh?
Jake:你开两辆车过来你开两辆车过来
Jake: You drove two cars over, you drove two cars over.
其他人:又堵车
Others: Another traffic jam.
Jake:这可以别人也开嘛
Jake: Others can drive too.
其他人:我想想我今天去海边王岛
Others: I'm thinking of going to Haibinwang Island today.
其他人:每次带的地方
Others: Every time I go.
其他人:下一站都会去新中关购物中
Others: The next stop will be Xinzhuang Shopping Center.
其他人:心或者林展购物中心玩耍
Others: Or Linzhan Shopping Center to hang out.
其他人:丝毫没有
Others: Not at all.
其他人:体会到海边王岛的危险的地方
Others: Experience the dangerous places on Wang Island by the sea.
其他人:明天几点
Others: What time tomorrow?
Jake:2点半
Jake: 2:30.
其他人:两点半
Others: 2:30.
Alice:还有这个酱
Alice: And this sauce.
Jake:你刚才说有这个伊罗币
Jake: You just said you have this Ero coin.
Jake:过来踩伊罗币
Jake: Come over and step on the Ero coin.
Alice:好多呀
Alice: There are so many!
Jake:嗯行
Jake: Okay, fine.
其他人：你家女朋友来了
Others: Your girlfriend is here.
Jake:白吃白喝就是白吃白喝
Jake: Free food and drink, just free food and drink.
其他人：白吃白喝
Others: Free food and drink.
其他人：让他们来白吃白喝
Others: Let them have free food and drink.
其他人:免费接送加白吃白喝嗯
Others: Free pick-up and free food and drink, yeah.
Alice:明天还负责接送的吗
Alice: Are we responsible for the pick-up tomorrow?
Alice:比较难吧
Alice: It's quite difficult, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 他们学校的同学
Lucia: Their schoolmates.
Jake:对他们北欧的可以方便
Jake: Yes, it's convenient for them in Northern Europe.
Jake:海淀那边的方便一点
Jake: It's a bit more convenient in Haidian.
Alice:这离地铁站远吗 1号线
Alice: Is this far from the subway station? Line 1.
其他人:不远
Others: Not far.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake:我们可以到地铁站那边接
Jake: We can pick them up from the subway station.
其他人:对可以给他搞一个
Others: Yeah, we can arrange that.
其他人:地铁站到那个接驳车
Others: A shuttle from the subway station.
其他人:大概半个小时一趟
Others: About every half hour.
其他人:还是来过一次哈哈哈
Others: Still, come over once, haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
其他人：所以咱走回去把他接走
Others: So, we walk back and pick him up.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：然后明天走回去大概15分钟就到了
Others: Then walk back tomorrow, it'll take about 15 minutes.
其他人:哦他可以不按照那个路
Others: Oh, he might not follow that route.
其他人:所以我不是借拨车吗
Others: So, isn't it a shuttle?
其他人：背着他过来
Others: Carry him over.
Jake:你你再租个车
Jake: You rent another car.
Jake:然后别死囊开
Jake: And don't drive it recklessly.
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Lucia: 是要用刀切一下呀
Lucia: Do we need to cut it with a knife?
Jake:哎这个蛋挞怎么是个饼啊
Jake: Hey, why does this egg tart look like a pancake?
Jake:一眼看到了
Jake: I saw it immediately.
Jake:很好看的一个
Jake: It's a really good-looking one.
Jake:哇
Jake: Wow.
其他人：睡眠睡眠
Others: Sleep, sleep.
其他人：黑色巧克力吗
Others: Is it dark chocolate?
Tasha: 哎刮刀呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the spatula?
Tasha: 我以为你拿了
Tasha: I thought you took it.
其他人：还有的没
Others: Is there any left?
Lucia: 我来吃
Lucia: I'll eat it.
其他人：带过来还是
Others: Should I bring it over?
Lucia: 刮刀在哪
Lucia: Where's the spatula?
其他人：刮刀这个
Others: This spatula?
Lucia: 呃不是这个是一个塑料的对吧
Lucia: Uh, not this one, the plastic one, right?
Lucia: 塑料的
Lucia: The plastic one.
Tasha: 速速的把它洗一下谢谢
Tasha: Quickly wash it, thank you.
Jake:麦当劳
Jake: McDonald's.
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm, hmm.
Jake:嗯嗯
Jake: Hmm, hmm.
Jake:我们高级东西可多
Jake: We have a lot of fancy stuff.
Jake:很多我们不理解的东西
Jake: Lots of things we don't understand.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Jake:抹哪啊
Jake: Where to spread it?
其他人：糖度是真的爆表
Others: The sugar level is off the charts.
Jake:抹抹头上
Jake: Spread it on your head.
Jake:一扫拍牙去
Jake: A sweep and it will stick to your teeth.
Tasha: 我每天都这样吃
Tasha: I eat like this every day.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:每天一公斤糖
Jake: A kilo of sugar every day.
其他人：已经受不了了
Others: Can't take it anymore.
其他人：吃一个晚饭
Others: Eat one meal.
Jake:这几天伙食太好了
Jake: The food has been so good these days.
Alice:剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Alice:剪刀在哪里
Alice: Where are the scissors?
其他人:这奶油是吧
Others: This is cream, right?
Jake:对就是奶油
Jake: Yeah, it's cream.
其他人：这剪下来了吗
Others: Did you cut it?
其他人:嗯不甜
Others: Hmm, not sweet.
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
其他人：最高评价不甜
Others: The highest rating is that it's not too sweet.
Jake:蛋挞加的奶油
Jake: The cream added to the egg tart.
其他人:有点像那个东西
Others: It kinda looks like that thing.
Alice:哈哈哈什么东西
Alice: Hahaha, what thing?
Jake:什么东西细数
Jake: What thing? Tell me more.
其他人:在喷点上面喷点巧克力
Others: Spray a bit of chocolate on top.
Tasha: 是的会喷的
Tasha: Yeah, it'll spray.
其他人:或者提拉米苏就更像
Others: Or if it's tiramisu, it would look more alike.
Tasha: 拿个刮刀能把它抹平吗
Tasha: Can a scraper smooth it out?
Tasha: 有没有一个刮刀
Tasha: Do we have a scraper?
Alice:我来吧
Alice: I'll do it.
其他人:你这个是专门设计的图案啊
Others: Is this a specially designed pattern?
Lucia: 昨天的那个
Lucia: Like the one from yesterday.
Alice:小刮刀吗
Alice: A small scraper?
Lucia: 这这种的
Lucia: Like this one.
Lucia: 这种的哎呦妈呀
Lucia: This kind, oh my.
Lucia: 对这个哎
Lucia: Yes, this one.
Lucia: 应该有有一片小的
Lucia: There should be a smaller one.
Lucia: 算了就用这个吧
Lucia: Never mind, just use this.
其他人:这个给我吧
Others: Give it to me.
其他人:既然都已经坏了
Others: Since it's already broken.
Jake:他们都是一样吗
Jake: Are they all the same?
Alice:那你来吧
Alice: Then you do it.
Jake:还是说就这几个
Jake: Or just these few?
Jake:黑的
Jake: The black ones.
Tasha: 白色的啊
Tasha: The white ones.
Tasha: 对怎么这么大
Tasha: Why is this one so big?
Alice:有小的没找到小的
Alice: There's a smaller one, but I couldn't find it.
其他人:这么刮大了
Others: This one scrapes too big.
Alice:再找找
Alice: Keep looking.
其他人:你这个都
Others: All of yours are...
Lucia: 有一个比那小的
Lucia: There's one smaller than that.
Lucia: 那天还用了
Lucia: We used it the other day.
Lucia: 但是不知道放哪了
Lucia: But I don't know where it went.
Alice:算了找不着好像
Alice: Never mind, can't find it.
Alice:那有没有
Alice: So, do we have...
其他人:你自己在家做蛋挞吃也是加这么多料
Others: Do you add this much stuff when you make egg tarts at home?
Alice:是这个吗
Alice: Is it this one?
Jake:哈哈哈这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, what's going on?
其他人:可以录的吗
Others: Can we record this?
Jake:可以
Jake: Alright.
Lucia: 呃我觉得这个也可以用
Lucia: Uh, I think we can use this too.
Lucia: 微微那个这种小刀也可以吧
Lucia: Tasha, this small knife should work too, right?
Lucia: 啊那就那就用这个吧
Lucia: Ah, then let's use this.
Lucia: 就用这个
Lucia: Just use this.
Lucia: 大的也行
Lucia: The big one works too.
其他人:直接给他铺平就行
Others: Just lay it flat for him.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
其他人:但是水果还没加
Others: But the fruits haven't been added yet.
其他人:这为什么这么稀呀
Others: Why is this so watery?
Tasha: 这还稀
Tasha: This is still watery?
Tasha: 这这边还有一个
Tasha: There's another one over here.
Alice:太会抹了
Alice: You're so good at spreading it.
Alice:你不会偷偷学过吧
Alice: Did you secretly learn this?
其他人:啊这还会抹
Others: Wow, you can actually spread it well.
其他人:这不都瞎抹的
Others: It's all just random spreading.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:这个应该快没那个存储了
Alice: This should be almost out of storage.
Jake:好看一下呃
Jake: Alright, let's check, uh...
Alice:停吗
Alice: Should we stop?
Alice:呃我看我的
Alice: Uh, I'll check mine.
Jake:就等没清楚就停吧
Jake: Just stop when it's not clear.
Jake:就是咱也还有
Jake: We still have some time.
Jake:还有还有半个小时
Jake: We still have half an hour.
Jake:啊没有
Jake: Ah, no.
Jake:就是这一轮
Jake: Just this round.
Alice:3333
Alice: 3333
Jake:33
Jake: 33
Jake:对啊半个小时
Jake: Yeah, half an hour.
Jake:一个小时40分钟
Jake: An hour and 40 minutes.
Alice:甜品师傅
Alice: Pastry chef.
其他人:刮刮腻子师傅
Others: Plaster master.
Jake:嗯把这换成叉子我觉得也挺好
Jake: Hmm, I think replacing this with a fork would be good too.
Lucia: 那个盘现在要铺上这个
Lucia: Now we need to lay this on the tray.
Lucia: 这个油纸吗
Lucia: This parchment paper, right?
Lucia: 觉得不铺好看
Lucia: I think it looks better without it.
Jake:那就不普
Jake: Then don't use it.
Lucia: 他蛋挞底下是有那个啊
Lucia: There's something under the tart, right?
Alice:嗯没有没有
Alice: Uh, no, no.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
其他人：你看可以了吧
Others: See, is it okay now?
Jake:那还是扑一下吧
Jake: Let's still dab it a bit.
Lucia: 因为那个刚拆开
Lucia: Because it was just opened.
Alice:就我刚开始擦的时候
Alice: When I first started wiping it...
Lucia: 就我刚用纸擦的时候它稍
Lucia: When I first wiped it with a tissue, it slightly...
Lucia: 微有点掉色其实因为它是个新的嘛
Lucia: The color slightly came off because it's new.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 所以要不然咱们安全起见
Lucia: So, to be safe...
Jake:那我们稍微扑一扑
Jake: Let's dab it a little.
Jake:稍微扑一扑
Jake: Dab it a bit.
Jake:小扑一下
Jake: Just a little dab.
其他人:哦我们明天车有多少人我
Others: Oh, how many people will be in the car tomorrow?
其他人：还有车吗
Others: Are there any more cars?
其他人：我
Others: I...
Lucia: 这个宽度好像还行
Lucia: The width seems okay.
其他人：你在哪上车
Others: Where will you get on the car?
其他人：你是从哪出发
Others: Where are you departing from?
其他人：我沟通
Others: I'll communicate.
Jake:来来
Jake: Come, come.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
其他人：你发我地址我去查
Others: Send me the address, I'll check it out.
Lucia: 那就把它撕齐一点
Lucia: Then tear it a bit more neatly.
Lucia: 我把这往里拽一拽
Lucia: I'll pull this inward.
其他人:他明天不来吗
Others: Is he not coming tomorrow?
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
其他人：那我带带一个我的来的朋友还可以
Others: Then I'll bring a friend who is coming with me, is that okay?
Jake:好
Jake: Sure.
Jake:你的车是哪来啊
Jake: Where is your car from?
其他人:他自己的车
Others: It's his own car.
其他人：刚好
Others: Just right.
其他人:啊
Others: Ah.
其他人：哦加上他
Others: Oh, adding him.
其他人：现在怎么播了
Others: How is it broadcasting now?
其他人：像感冒发紫糖
Others: Like a cold syrup.
其他人：哦好高级
Others: Oh, so fancy.
Lucia: 觉这个长度应该差不多
Lucia: I think this length is about right.
Jake:来请坐
Jake: Please, have a seat.
其他人:我有义有吾有义
Others: I have justice, I have none, I have justice.
Lucia: 咦可恶
Lucia: Ugh, annoying.
Jake:来我来玩
Jake: Come on, let me play.
Lucia: 稍微有点歪
Lucia: It's a bit crooked.
Jake:我要玩嗯玩不了
Jake: I want to play, but I can't.
Jake:玩不了呃
Jake: I can't play, ugh.
Tasha: 你可以把黄豆粉拿来
Tasha: You can bring the soybean flour.
Jake:土豆粉
Jake: Potato flour.
Alice:黄豆粉
Alice: Soybean flour.
Lucia: 我感觉左边这个没有撕齐
Lucia: I feel like the left side isn't torn evenly.
Lucia: 要不再重撕一下
Lucia: Maybe tear it again?
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Jake:熟黄豆粉
Jake: Cooked soybean flour.
Lucia: 对就这刚才我手一抖撕歪了
Lucia: Yes, just now my hand shook and tore it crooked.
Alice:你要玩吗
Alice: Do you want to play?
Lucia: 这边这个比较齐
Lucia: This side is more even.
其他人:卧槽你看
Others: Wow, look.
其他人:变这么好看了
Others: It looks so good now.
其他人:对哼
Others: Yeah, hum.
Jake:玩手机玩了10分钟变好
Jake: Played on the phone for 10 minutes, it looks better now.
Tasha: 抖就这样抖就可以了
Tasha: Just shake it like this, it's fine.
其他人:变好看了
Others: It looks better.
Tasha: 下一个
Tasha: Next one.
Tasha: 等等等等
Tasha: Wait, wait, wait.
Tasha: 哎呦哎没事没事
Tasha: Oops, it's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 底下稍微有点湿
Lucia: It's a bit wet underneath.
Lucia: 没事这个
Lucia: No worries, this...
Lucia: 这个纸不剩水可以
Lucia: This paper doesn't absorb water well.
其他人：要不直接就这样
Others: Maybe just leave it like this.
Tasha: 没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 再抖时间长了才会痛
Tasha: If you shake it too long, it'll hurt.
Lucia: 要不然拿张纸擦一下
Lucia: Or wipe it with a paper towel.
Tasha: 好了吗直接撒我嘴里
Tasha: Is it ready? Pour it into my mouth.
其他人：直接撒我嘴里
Others: Pour it into my mouth.
其它人：哈哈哈
Jake:来来来来来张嘴
Jake: Come on, open your mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈这一一眼睛那是
Jake: Hahaha, it's in your eye.
Alice:哈哈哈
Tasha: 下一个不弄抹茶的吗
Tasha: Next one, aren't we using matcha?
Alice:不弄抹茶的吗
Alice: Aren't we using matcha?
其他人:我靠高级
Others: Wow, high class.
其他人：那个抹茶能直接冲
Others: Can the matcha be used directly?
Jake:确实厉害
Jake: It's really amazing.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Jake:那剩下来怎么办
Jake: So what do we do with the rest?
Jake:只能倒进嘴里
Jake: Just pour it into your mouth.
Jake:哈哈哈这怎么办啊
Jake: Hahaha, what do we do?
Jake:这个倒掉那好吧
Jake: Pour it out? Alright then.
其他人：到这里
Others: Right here.
Jake:真的哈哈哈
Jake: Really, hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈那个没法炫我嘴里
Lucia: Hahaha, can't fit all that in my mouth.
Jake:好那我现鼠标上吧哈哈哈
Jake: Okay, I'll pour it on the mouse then, hahaha.
Lucia: 会炫我脸上
Lucia: It'll get all over my face.
其他人： 抹茶粉啊
Others: Matcha powder, huh.
Tasha: 所以我不舍得这样子倒
Tasha: That's why I can't bear to pour it out like this.
其他人:抹茶粉太贵了嗯
Others: Matcha powder is too expensive, yeah.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Mhm.
Jake:真的那我再多撒点
Jake: Really? Then I'll sprinkle more.
Tasha: 我靠真的好吃
Tasha: Wow, it's really delicious.
Alice:什么
其他人：美味
Others: Delicious.
Alice:好吃美味
Alice: Tasty, delicious.
Lucia: 跟没加一样
Lucia: It's like there's nothing added.
Jake:这是最高评价了哈哈哈
Jake: That's the highest compliment, hahaha.
Tasha: 好吧
Jake:抹茶粉多贵啊
Jake: Matcha powder is so expensive.
Tasha: 呃一克一克两块钱
Tasha: Uh, it's two yuan per gram.
其他人：我去一克两块钱
Others: Wow, two yuan per gram.
其他人：那还比黄金便宜点
Others: That's still cheaper than gold.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 那便宜好多
Tasha: That's way cheaper.
其他人：哇好看好看
Others: Wow, it looks amazing.
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome.
其他人：确实
Others: Indeed.
Jake:没关系没关系
Jake: It's alright, it's alright.
Tasha: 边角料全部都炫掉
Tasha: Eat up all the scraps.
Tasha: 哎嗯
Tasha: Hey, mhm.
Jake:还没撒粉呢
Jake: Haven't sprinkled the powder yet.
Tasha: 嗯就就一直在洒
Tasha: Mhm, just keep sprinkling.
Jake:黄金还没
Jake: Gold hasn't been...
Jake:洒了小黄金
Jake: Sprinkled some gold.
其他人:我靠那一会没撒完
Other: Oh no, I didn't finish sprinkling.
其他人:抹茶粉可以炫耀谁
Other: Who can show off matcha powder?
其他人:我很喜欢的
Other: I really like it.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay.
其他人：这个抹茶粉挺好吃的牛逼
Other: This matcha powder tastes really good, awesome.
其他人：牛逼
Other: Awesome.
Tasha: 好撒吧呵呵
Tasha: Alright, sprinkle it, haha.
其他人：这这个也经常倒这么一点撒
Other: This one is often poured out like this.
Tasha: 呃喜喜斯科草莓
Tasha: Uh, Sisqo strawberry.
其他人:这是
Other: This is...
其他人:这是有排版的呀
Other: This has layout, huh.
其他人:我靠
Other: Oh my.
其他人:非常的高级
Other: Very high-end.
其他人：可以可以
Other: Pretty good.
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个上面要放草莓
Other: Why put a strawberry on one of the six?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
其他人:为什么一个6一个5个
Other: Why one of the six?
Tasha: 被他偷走了一个
Tasha: He stole one.
其他人：这个确实不错
Other: This is indeed good.
其他人:那我再偷吃一个可乐
Other: Then I'll steal a cola.
Lucia: 你想吃哪个
Lucia: Which one do you want to eat?
其他人:你让我吃哪个
Other: Which one will you let me eat?
Lucia: 你想吃哪个吃哪个
Lucia: Eat whichever you want.
Alice:切不切
Alice: To cut or not?
Tasha: 不切
Tasha: Don't cut.
Katrina: 第一个是在杭州线下买的
Katrina: The first one I bought offline in Hangzhou.
Katrina: 我买的是
Katrina: I bought it...
Katrina: 对线下门店只有几个城市有
Katrina: Yes, only a few cities have offline stores.
Katrina:  嗯北京国贸也有
Katrina: Hmm, Beijing International Trade also has one.
Katrina: 我想想
Katrina: Let me think...
Katrina: 对他我一共有几个
Katrina: Yes, I have a few of them.
Katrina:  我买了这个
Katrina: I bought this one.
Katrina: 他们都属于一个系列的
Katrina: They all belong to the same series.
Katrina: 叫什么波
Katrina: What's it called, wave?
Tasha: 我的天呐
Tasha: Oh my god.
Jake:哦好吸
Jake: Oh, so attractive.
其他人：确实这个奶油为啥这么吸
Other: Indeed, why is this cream so attractive?
Tasha: 因为本来是吸的
Tasha: Because it's supposed to be attractive.
Tasha: 但是这个蛋挞太热了给它融了
Tasha: But this egg tart was too hot and melted it.
Alice:给它融了
Alice: It melted it.
其他人： 好好哈哈哈哈好
Others: Hahaha, good one!
Katrina: 这很这很舒服
Katrina: This feels so good.
Katrina: 这跟这一个系列的
Katrina: This is part of the series.
Tasha: 快吃快吃
Tasha: Eat quickly, eat quickly.
Tasha: 别拍了
Tasha: Stop filming.
Tasha: 大家快吃
Tasha: Everyone, eat up!
其他人：找了半天饺子都没有找
Others: We've been searching for dumplings but couldn't find any.
其他人：：没有找着合适
Others: Couldn't find the right ones.
其他人：还有饺子
Others: There are still dumplings left.
Tasha: 快吃
Tasha: Hurry up and eat.
Jake:我每天都在这种surprising中
Jake: Every day I'm in such surprising moments.
Alice:等我一下
Alice: Wait for me.
Jake:来吃吃吃
Jake: Come on, eat, eat, eat.
Jake:大师您先吃您先吃
Jake: Master, you go ahead and eat first.
Tasha: 您先吃
Tasha: You eat first.
Jake:哈哈哈哎
Jake: Hahaha, hey.
Tasha: 哎这个真的擦了吗
Tasha: Hey, did you really wipe this clean?
Lucia: 擦了但是他那个渣就会粘在上面
Lucia: I wiped it, but the crumbs stick to it.
Lucia: 就是厨房纸会被他那个木头挂掉
Lucia: The kitchen paper gets caught on the wood.
Tasha: 嗯嗯嗯
Tasha: Hmm, yeah.
Lucia: 所以我那那里面也垫一个
Lucia: So, I put another layer inside.
Lucia: 等一下我刚哎刚那个这个
Lucia: Wait a second, I just, uh, this one.
Lucia: 这个要垫一下吗
Lucia: Does this need another layer?
Lucia: 因为我擦的时候感觉它真的有点
Lucia: Because when I wiped it, it really felt a bit...
其他人:傻逼企鹅狗都别买
Others: Stupid penguin, don't buy it.
Jake:什么意思啊
Jake: What do you mean?
其他人:没事我买这个
Others: No worries, I bought this.
其他人:就是我女朋友的前男友
Others: It was my girlfriend's ex-boyfriend.
其他人:送我女朋友的是企鹅
Others: He gave my girlfriend a penguin.
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅啊
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin?
Jake:是企鹅啊
Jake: A penguin?
其他人:他送给他前男友的是企鹅哦
Others: He gave his ex-boyfriend a penguin, oh.
其他人:我女朋友的前男友送我女朋友的
Others: My girlfriend's ex-boyfriend gave her one too.
其他人:也是企鹅
Others: Also a penguin.
Katrina: 就是他被绿的那个
Katrina: That’s the one who got cheated on.
其他人:不是不是不是我现在的女朋友
Others: No, no, no, my current girlfriend.
Katrina: 你现任女朋友的前男友哦
Katrina: Your current girlfriend's ex-boyfriend?
其他人:你天呐
Others: Oh my god.
其他人：今天需要怎么放
Others: How do we place it today?
Jake:建立了连接
Jake: Made a connection.
其他人：反正就是企鹅不好
Others: Anyway, penguins are just bad.
Katrina: 嗯企鹅坏
Katrina: Yeah, penguins are bad.
其他人：那我买狐狸
Others: Then I'll buy a fox.
其他人：我买狐狸
Others: I'll buy a fox.
其他人：我买企鹅
Others: I'll buy a penguin.
Katrina: 企鹅坏人好
Katrina: Penguins are bad, people are good.
其他人：坏狐狸好
Others: Bad foxes are good.
其他人:好我立马辞职
Others: Alright, I'll resign immediately.
其他人:为了你我加入自己哈哈哈
Others: For you, I'll join myself haha.
Katrina: 哎呦哈哈哈
Katrina: Oh my gosh, haha.
Katrina: 没货了
Katrina: It's out of stock.
Katrina: 再给你找一
Katrina: Let me find you another one.
Katrina: 这种这种就是库存就几个的
Katrina: This kind, this kind is just a few in stock.
Katrina: 就一般是个人海淘
Katrina: Usually it's someone buying from overseas.
Jake:我先把这个收了吧
Jake: I'll take this first.
Katrina:  就是他们从官网下单
Katrina: They order from the official website.
Katrina: 然后要等一个月什么的
Katrina: And then have to wait for a month or so.
Katrina: 然后这种的话就比较真
Katrina: And these are usually more authentic.
Lucia: 哦他也塌了
Lucia: Oh, it's collapsing too.
Jake:我靠这很难很难不谈
Jake: Damn, this is really hard to discuss.
Katrina: 要么就官网买
Katrina: Or just buy from the official website.
Katrina: 官网经常没货
Katrina: The official website often runs out of stock.
Katrina: 我觉得这个系列性价比比较高
Katrina: I think this series is pretty cost-effective.
Katrina: 像这种小11
Katrina: Like this small one.
Katrina: 你看这种
Katrina: Look at this.
Katrina: 这种系列就很性价比比较高
Katrina: This series is really cost-effective.
Katrina: 你看160斤就这么大你知道吗
Katrina: Look, 160 pounds and it's this big, you know?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Katrina: ：它小这是买好
Katrina: It's small, this is a good buy.
其他人：这种人呢
Others: These kind of people.
其他人：嗯那就别生气了
Others: Hmm, then don't be angry.
其他人：不是说买这个
Others: Didn't we say to buy this?
其他人：对对对这个是真选
Others: Yes, yes, this is the real deal.
Jake:我看看
Jake: Let me see.
其他人：非常的好
Others: It's really good.
其他人：非常的好看啊这
Others: It's really good-looking.
Jake:这是狐狸
Jake: This is a fox.
Katrina: 我给你找一找感觉
Katrina: Let me find you some feeling.
Katrina: 你看这都是一个系列
Katrina: Look, these are all in the same series.
Katrina: 居然吗断货吗
Katrina: Really, it's out of stock?
Katrina: 这狐狸这狐狸有点丑
Katrina: This fox, this fox is kind of ugly.
其他人：嗯你的那个店家已经缺货了吗
Others: Hmm, is your store out of stock already?
Katrina: 嗯才几天啊这
Katrina: Hmm, how many days has it been?
Alice:可爱你
Alice: Love you.
Tasha: 用一个容器
Tasha: Use a container.
Jake:容器
Jake: Container.
Jake:真圆
Jake: So round.
其他人：靠
Others: Damn.
其他人：京东上倒有369
Others: There's one for 369 on JD.
其他人：有点过分了
Others: That's a bit much.
Katrina: 他怎么溢价呢还
Katrina: Why is it priced so high?
Alice:可以可以
Alice: It's possible, it's possible.
Tasha: 咖啡液咖啡液
Tasha: Coffee liquid, coffee liquid.
Alice:在这
Alice: Here it is.
其他人：这还用咖啡液
Others: Does this need coffee liquid?
其他人：我说我直接这么切了
Others: I said I'll just cut it like this.
Tasha: 你切
Tasha: You cut it.
Tasha: 但是你可以用那个切刀洗咖啡液
Tasha: But you can use that cutter to wash the coffee liquid.
Alice:咖啡液
Alice: Coffee liquid.
Lucia: 对是那天那个刀吗
Lucia: Right, is it that knife from that day?
Lucia: 那天那天杨老板切蛋糕那个刀吗
Lucia: The knife Jake used to cut the cake that day?
Tasha: 对对
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:哦哦猜到
Jake: Oh, oh, you guessed it.
Tasha: 你用这个也行
Tasha: You can use this too.
Alice:一样的
Alice: It's the same.
其他人：闲鱼很多假的耶
Others: There are many fakes on Xianyu.
Jake:这个吧
Jake: This one?
Tasha: 嗯也可以
Tasha: Hmm, that works too.
Lucia: 咖啡液是咱们那天那个绿色的那个吗
Lucia: Is the coffee liquid the green one we used that day?
Lucia: 就是这也行
Lucia: This one works too.
Jake:瑞幸咖啡业
Jake: Luckin Coffee.
Alice:冷萃的
Alice: Cold brew.
Jake:不知道为什么出现在这里
Jake: I don't know why it's here.
Jake:不知道怎么是怎么就买了呢
Jake: I don't know how I ended up buying it.
Alice:太讲究了
Alice: So particular.
Lucia: 他突然就出现在了需要用的地方
Lucia: It just appeared right where we needed it.
Lucia: 很好
Lucia: Great.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh my.
Tasha: 怪会摆的
Lucia: 哎呦
Lucia: Oh my.
Jake:有经验走吧走吧
Jake: Experienced, let's go, let's go.
Jake:怎么买
Jake: How do we buy it?
Jake:其他人：
Jake: Others:
其他人：通过价格判断他可能只有149
Others: Judging by the price, it might only be 149.
其他人:他就看库存就能看出来
Others: Just looking at the stock, you can tell.
其他人:这个东西他觉得真不真哦
Others: He wonders if it's real or not.
其他人:哎这还都响
Others: Hey, it all rings.
Jake:新乐器
Jake: New instrument.
Tasha: 拿一个
Tasha: Grab one.
Alice: 25毫升还要多少
Alice: 25 milliliters, how much more do you need?
Tasha: 呃 25毫升刚刚好哦
Tasha: Uh, 25 milliliters is just right.
其他人:确实哦这个咖啡业买还派上用场
Others: Indeed, this coffee actually comes in handy.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
Lucia: 本来是想夹带私货的是吧
Lucia: You originally planned to sneak some extras, right?
其他人：是吧本来是想稍稍加载私货的
Others: Right, originally planned to sneak some extras.
Tasha: 等一下等一下
Katrina: 我靠居然买了一家奶酪
Lucia: 没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 其实那个奶酪也是我家带的死货
Lucia: Actually, that cheese is also some old stock from my place.
Lucia: 不过反正也吃上了哈哈
Lucia: But anyway, we've eaten it, haha.
Katrina: 我靠还没拍照
Katrina: Damn, we haven't taken a photo yet.
其他人:我靠这摆盘有点怎么怎么
Others: Damn, this plating is kind of...
其他人:又低了一下头就已经摆完了
Others: Just lowered my head and it's done.
其他人:我操你吃完了
Others: Damn, you finished it.
其他人:放上去放上去
Others: Put it back, put it back.
其他人: 放上去
Others: Put it back.
Katrina: 这今天晚上吃的还是明天的
Katrina: Are we eating this tonight or tomorrow?
Tasha: 要热水热水热水热水
Tasha: Need hot water, hot water, hot water, hot water.
Alice:热水壶在那呢
Alice: The kettle is over there.
Alice:他他脚那
Alice: By his foot.
Alice:这个这个这桌子底下
Alice: This, this, under the table.
Tasha: 为什么要把他们强行塞在一起
Tasha: Why are you forcing them together?
Jake:方便拍照
Jake: For easier photos.
Jake:咱还有道具呢
Jake: We also have props.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:在后面再摆一个
Jake: Put another one in the back.
Jake:显得很多
Jake: Makes it look like a lot.
Alice:你你能不能把这个汇源果汁挡一下
Alice: Can you cover that Huiyuan juice?
Jake:我们有真真两大盆
Jake: We have two big pots.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:就这样
Alice: Just like this.
Alice:勤劳
Alice: Hardworking.
Jake:现在还有什
Jake: What else is there now...
提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu.
Jake:还有什么
Jake: What else...
Jake:提拉米苏嗯
Jake: Tiramisu, hmm.
Lucia: 要用哪个盒子呀
Lucia: Which box should we use?
Lucia: 垫纸吗用这用这个盒吗还是
Lucia: Do we need to put paper inside? Should we use this box or...
Alice:用那个就行吧
Alice: Just use that one.
Lucia: 那把这俩挪到一个上
Lucia: Then let's move these two into one.
Jake:对这个先洗
Jake: Yeah, wash this one first.
Jake:都是买的
Jake: They're all bought.
Jake:这玩意咋洗
Jake: How to wash this thing...
Jake:刚刚路亚怎么洗
Jake: How did Lua wash it earlier?
Jake:就擦了擦是吧
Jake: Just wiped it, right?
Lucia: 我拿这个擦的
Lucia: I wiped it with this.
Lucia: 就是沾点水擦
Lucia: Just wet it a bit and wipe.
Lucia: 但是就是因为这是木头的
Lucia: But because this is wood...
Lucia: 所以它就是上面的
Lucia: It might have splinters.
Lucia: 有可能会有刺
Lucia: It might scratch off a bit.
Lucia: 会把这个稍微刮下来
Lucia: So be careful.
Tasha: 热水好了给我一下热水好了给我一下
Tasha: The hot water is ready, give it to me. The hot water is ready, give it to me.
Lucia: 呃那个好像不能直接用
Lucia: Uh, that one can't be used directly.
Lucia: 就是上面不是有那个洗洁精吗
Lucia: There's detergent on it, isn't there?
Lucia: 如果你直接擦好就会留在上面
Lucia: If you wipe it directly, it will stay on.
Lucia: 或者能直接洗一下可能也行
Lucia: Or maybe you can wash it directly, that could work too.
Jake:那我过水了
Jake: Then I'll rinse it.
Jake:行我觉得我直接洗一洗
Jake: Okay, I think I'll just wash it directly.
Lucia: 这个也洗一下吧
Lucia: Wash this one too.
Tasha: 完了这个盆放不下
Tasha: This bowl doesn't fit.
Tasha: 有没有放个大点的盆给我
Tasha: Do we have a bigger bowl for me?
Tasha: 盆盆盆
Tasha: Bowl, bowl, bowl.
Lucia: 等一下啊哎
Lucia: Wait a second, hey.
Jake:那个大碗是吧
Jake: That big bowl, right?
Jake:哦挺好
Jake: Oh, it's pretty good.
Alice:这个吧
Alice: This one?
Lucia: 这个不太行
Lucia: This one isn't quite right.
Alice:这个或者这个这个吧
Alice: This one or this one, this one then.
Alice:这个底深
Alice: This one has a deeper bottom.
Lucia: 这有俩不过这俩应该是一样大的
Lucia: There are two here, but they should be the same size.
Alice:用这个吧
Alice: Use this one.
Lucia: 哦那个碗
Lucia: Oh, that bowl.
Lucia: 对那碗能沉的更深一点
Lucia: Yeah, that bowl can go deeper.
Alice:我再涮一下吧
Alice: Let me rinse it again.
Jake:戴眼镜吧
Jake: Wear glasses.
Alice:手指饼干呢
Alice: Where are the finger biscuits?
Lucia: 这要擦一下吗
Lucia: Do we need to wipe this?
Lucia: 要要
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 不用了不用了哦
Tasha: No, no, it's fine.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:蘸一下
Alice: Dip it a bit.
其他人:一下蘸
Others: Just dip it.
Alice:不是蘸一下咖啡
Alice: No, dip it in the coffee.
其他人:一下咖啡蘸一下那个蘸一下咖啡
Others: Dip it in the coffee, dip it in the coffee.
Alice:蘸一下那个
Alice: Dip that.
Alice:没事等一会吧
Alice: Never mind, wait a bit.
其他人:然后我
Others: And then I...
Alice:烤啊不烤就直接放那
Alice: Roast it, if not, just place it there.
Alice:蘸一下然后放在那个夹层里
Alice: Dip it, then place it in the layer.
Shure: 外面是不是有点小冷
Shure: Isn't it a bit chilly outside?
Shure: 谁开的 16度
Shure: Who set it to 16 degrees?
Tasha: 没了
Tasha: It's gone.
Shure: 你在家不挨揍吗
Shure: Don't you get beaten at home?
其他人：我刚才要热死了
Others: I was about to overheat.
Jake:金爷
Jake: Jin Ye.
Alice:你是突然出现的吗
Alice: Did you just suddenly appear?
Alice:刚刚你在这吗
Alice: Were you here just now?
Shure: 我刚不在这
Shure: I wasn't here just now.
Shure: 我刚开会
Shure: I was in a meeting.
其他人：老赵应该感受到
Others: Lao Zhao should feel it.
其他人：一种非常不应该戴眼镜的人
Others: Someone who shouldn't be wearing glasses.
其他人：然后发现16组
Others: Then found the 16 groups.
其他人：然后跟那个
Others: Then with that...
Shure: 牛排呢吃没了都
Shure: Where's the steak? Is it all gone?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Shure: 牛排吃没了
Shure: The steak is gone.
Jake:我怎么调啊
Jake: How do I adjust this?
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go.
Jake:为什么26了都
Jake: Why is it already 26?
Alice:这呢
Alice: Here it is.
Tasha: 这个咖啡
Tasha: This coffee.
Alice:这个这个咖啡咖啡液奥
Alice: This, this coffee liquid.
Alice:提拉米苏是
Alice: Tiramisu is...
Alice:吧对
Alice: Right, yes.
Tasha: 滚两圈
Tasha: Roll it twice.
其他人：直接搁里边啊
Others: Just put it in directly.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
其他人：对这搁的是什么呢
Others: Yeah, what is this made of?
Tasha:  手指饼干
Tasha: Ladyfingers.
Jake:想吃啊已经
Jake: I already want to eat it.
Tasha: 哇好高级
Tasha: Wow, so fancy.
Tasha: 哎你这样放太多了
Tasha: Hey, you put too much.
Alice:太快了
Alice: Too fast.
Tasha: 这饼干全部都不能要了
Tasha: All these cookies are ruined.
Alice:哎呀不行了
Alice: Oh no, it's not good.
其他人:没事没事我这还有几个
Others: It's okay, I have a few more.
Tasha: 呃这几个都不能要了哦
Tasha: Ugh, these can't be used anymore.
其他人：它已经软了
Others: They've gone soft.
Alice:对对我来吧
Alice: Yes, let me do it.
Lucia: 拿个勺把它舀出来
Lucia: Use a spoon to scoop it out.
其他人：对拿筷子
Others: Yes, use chopsticks.
Tasha: 这几个把咖啡液全部都吸走了
Tasha: These soaked up all the coffee liquid.
Jake:没事没事
Jake: It's okay.
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay.
其他人：问题不是很大
Others: It's not a big deal.
Jake:你先吃了
Jake: You eat first.
其他人：而且那还有一包呢
Others: And there's another pack.
Tasha: 继续搁吧
Tasha: Keep putting it in.
其他人：而且咖啡液也还有
Others: And there's more coffee liquid.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 这几个要不要弄个咸鸭蛋
Tasha: Should we add some salted duck eggs?
Jake:咸鸭蛋
Jake: Salted duck eggs?
其他人：他也不会吸太多吃过吧
Others: It won't soak up too much, have you tried it?
Shure: 吃过吧小伙伴
Shure: Have you tried it, buddy?
Jake:吃还是常吃
Jake: Yes, I eat it often.
其他人：要不再弄个咖啡
Others: Or should we make more coffee?
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Tasha: 要重新弄可能
Tasha: We might need to remake it.
其他人:没事没事还有那个
Others: It's fine, we still have that.
其他人:算了不行我还给你手穿了
Others: Forget it, no way, I'll give it back to you.
Tasha: 搁
Tasha: Place it.
其他人:然后再来一盘就能吃了
Others: Then make another plate and it will be ready to eat.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Right.
Tasha: 还要再来一盘
Tasha: We need to make another plate.
Tasha: 就就这些
Tasha: That's all.
其他人：没有那还有一包
Others: No, there's still another pack.
其他人：咖啡够吗不够就少放点
Others: Is there enough coffee? If not, just put a little less.
Lucia: 这个可以放回去
Lucia: This can be put back.
Lucia: 要把它咬出来
Lucia: You need to bite it out.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
其他人:这上面不是撒了一层糖吗
Others: Isn't there a layer of sugar on top?
其他人:为什么这个有菠萝味啊
Others: Why does this have a pineapple flavor?
Alice:里面放菠萝了
Alice: There's pineapple inside.
其他人:我放菠萝
Others: I added pineapple.
Alice:夹带了
Alice: It sneaked in.
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe.
Tasha: 上面上面有没有的
Tasha: Is there any on top?
Tasha: 上面没有
Tasha: There's none on top.
Lucia: 这个是没有的
Lucia: This one doesn't have it.
Tasha: 你失败了
Tasha: You failed.
Tasha: 刘帅受到了大家的批评
Tasha: Choiszt got criticized by everyone.
Shure: 放假了就一个人批评这个
Shure: During the break, only one person got criticized.
Jake:来表扬一下
Jake: Come on, let's give some praise.
Jake:这有没有菠萝不一定
Jake: Whether this has pineapple is not certain.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Alice:没有
Jake:这这有菠萝吗
Jake: Does this have pineapple?
Jake:这个没有
Jake: This one doesn't.
Alice:这个没有
Alice: This one doesn't.
其他人：以前那个有菠萝吗
Others: Did the previous one have pineapple?
Tasha: 没有了你看你要是不拿走刚刚好
Tasha: No, if you don't take it away, it's just right.
其他人：那把这个挤一下
Others: Then squeeze this one a bit.
其他人:就是拿手上捏
Others: Just squeeze it with your hand.
其他人:也可以来几个
Others: You can have a few more.
其他人:没有提拉米苏味的或者其他味的
Others: There are no tiramisu flavors or other flavors?
其他人:抹茶味的
Others: Matcha flavor.
Tasha: 怎么样都是需要手指饼干的
Tasha: No matter what, you need ladyfingers.
其他人:或者可乐味
Others: Or cola flavor.
Shure: 好吃吗这是咸鸭蛋
Shure: Is it tasty? This is salted duck egg.
Jake:每追过一台
Jake: Every single one.
Shure: 真香
Shure: Smells good.
Jake:听说过高油咸鸭蛋吗
Jake: Have you heard of high-oil salted duck eggs?
Shure: 听说过
Shure: I've heard of it.
其他人：这不是汪曾祺的
Others: Isn't that by Wang Zengqi?
其他人:小说嘛嗯
Others: A novel, right?
其他人:非常的真的吗
Others: Really?
其他人:好吃嗯
Others: Delicious, yeah.
Shure: 真的是王胜奇的小说吗
Shure: Is it really from Wang Shengqi's novel?
其他人:好像是个高油鸭蛋
Others: Seems like it’s a high-oil duck egg.
Shure: 我是个仗义
Shure: I’m straightforward.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don’t know.
其他人:我也不知道
Others: I don’t know either.
其他人:我只是撕
Others: I’m just tearing it.
其他人:要捏一个嘛
Others: You need to squeeze it, right?
Tasha: 不知道该怎么办
Tasha: I don’t know what to do.
其他人：没事少一个也无所谓
Others: It’s okay, missing one is no big deal.
Alice:你把这个搁这这底下这个
Alice: Put this here, the bottom one.
其他人：来一个
Others: Come on, one more.
其他人:好吃的吃这个你也吃
Others: It's tasty, you should eat too.
Shure: 牛排怎么这么受欢迎呢
Shure: Why is steak so popular?
Jake:哎是直接吃吗
Jake: Hey, do you eat it directly?
Jake:饱了和和会吧
Jake: Are you full?
Shure: 我出来都没了
Shure: I came out and it’s all gone.
Jake:休息一下
Jake: Take a break.
Shure: 我吃了个饺子
Shure: I had a dumpling.
其他人:这奶油吗
Others: Is this cream?
其他人：果汁奶油吗
Others: Fruit juice cream?
Alice:这是
Alice: This is...
其他人:是这是什么东西
Others: What is this?
Jake:提拉米苏
Jake: Tiramisu.
Alice:嗯这个
Alice: Yeah, this.
其他人:提拉米苏
Others: Tiramisu.
Tasha: 这个先不加
Tasha: Don’t add this yet.
其他人：方方正正的
Others: Perfectly square.
Jake:他可能考完之后就是方方正正的
Jake: Maybe after baking, it becomes perfectly square.
Tasha: 还没切呢
Tasha: It’s not cut yet.
Tasha: ：有没有可能等会切一下就是了
Tasha: Maybe we can cut it later.
Lucia: 这不加还需要再来一层卤汁
Lucia: If you don’t add it, you need another layer of marinade.
Jake:他考完之后他就变成了一层又一层
Jake: After baking, it becomes layer after layer.
Tasha: 拇指饼干没了
Tasha: We're out of ladyfingers.
Alice:没就一包
Alice: We only had one pack.
其他人：就就这么多包
Others: Yeah, that's all we had.
其他人：这一层大家都吃不完
Others: No one can finish all of this layer.
Tasha: 再来再来再来调一层
Tasha: Let's make another layer.
Tasha: 再来调一层
Lucia: 嗯咖啡
Lucia: Hmm, coffee.
Jake:没崩到你吧
Jake: It didn't splash on you, did it?
Tasha: 没事没事没事
Tasha: It's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
Tasha: 还差200克热水
Tasha: We still need 200 grams of hot water.
Tasha: 再烧200克
Tasha: Boil another 200 grams.
Jake:师傅没开机啊大师
Jake: The master didn't turn on the machine, huh?
Jake:怎么再再准一下
Jake: How about you check again?
Jake:再给人再给人准一下
Jake: Check it for us again.
Tasha: 糖
Tasha: Sugar.
Tasha: 烧20克就行了
Tasha: Boil just 20 grams.
Alice:200
Alice: 200.
Tasha: 你加的越多烧的越慢
Tasha: The more you add, the slower it boils.
Lucia: 少倒倒点
Lucia: Pour a little less.
其他人:那其实如果你这个都泡了以后泡的话
Others: If you soak all of it, those biscuits should be added too.
其他人:就刚才那点那几个饼干也应该加进去
Others: Just like the ones we soaked earlier.
其他人:就也可以加进去先烤开了
Others: You can add them first and bake them.
Alice:你抄底的时候可能拖不住
其他人:但是你现在加完了以后
Others: But after you add it now,
其他人:他底下不也没泡了
Others: it won't soak through the bottom.
Shure: 我的可乐呢
Shure: Where's my cola?
Alice:啊
其他人:就你现在加完这个
Others: After you add this,
其他人:这不也稀的吗
Others: it will be thinner.
其他人:那你底下那种那边有个空盒
Others: There's an empty box over there.
Jake:那边有空喝那没人喝的可乐
Jake: There's some untouched cola over there.
Jake:一喝这里头
Jake: Pour it in here.
Alice:啊没事还会冷藏
Alice: Ah, it's okay, it'll chill.
其他人：哎我草你怎么了
Others: Hey, what happened?
其他人：我草别吓我
Others: Oh my, don't scare me.
Tasha: 谁摔了没事
Tasha: Did someone fall? It's okay.
Shure: 你的你的眼镜没电了
Shure: Your glasses are out of battery.
Lucia: 刚刚还有电
Lucia: They just had battery.
Lucia: 刚刚在楼上
Lucia: Just now, upstairs.
Lucia: 可能是没电
Lucia: Maybe they're out of battery.
Shure: 可能是你的脸突然把它抱内存了
Shure: Maybe your face suddenly drained its memory.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 还没有连上吧
Tasha: Haven't connected yet, right?
Shure: 我们是不是没有排练歌曲啊家人们
Shure: Have we not rehearsed the song, guys?
Alice:是这样的
Alice: Yeah, that's right.
Alice:QA也没有准备吧
Alice: And we didn't prepare the QA, right?
Shure: 啊哈哈哈
Shure: Ahahaha
Alice:还有QA
Alice: There's still the QA.
Shure: 哦QA也没做
Shure: Oh, QA also isn't done.
Alice:QA
Alice: QA.
Jake:QA做一个呗
Jake: Let's do a QA.
Alice:还有藏币
Alice: And the coins.
Jake:藏币现藏币
Jake: Hide the coins now.
Jake:大家大伙
Jake: Everyone, everyone.
Jake:大伙先藏币吧
Jake: Everyone, hide the coins first.
Jake:币在这
Jake: The coins are here.
Alice:币呢
Alice: Where are the coins?
Jake:这是这是币吗
Jake: Is this, is this the coins?
Lucia: 实际上我屋甚至还没整理
Lucia: Actually, I haven't even tidied up my room.
Alice:这是币吗
Alice: Are these the coins?
Jake:不是不是
Jake: No, no.
Alice:还没装修呢哈哈
Alice: Haven't even decorated yet, haha.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 每天都有好多事
Lucia: There's so much to do every day.
Jake:那工人怎么
Jake: What about the workers?
Jake:咱怎么办
Jake: What do we do?
Jake:工人已经救不了了是吧
Jake: The workers can't be saved, right?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 场面有点失控
Lucia: The situation is a bit out of control.
Jake:一直是失
Jake: It's always out of...
Jake:一直是失控的状态
Jake: It's always out of control.
其他人：哈哈
Others: Haha.
Lucia: 那要不摆烂吧
Lucia: How about we just let it go?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 快勾人快快勾人
Shure: Hurry and hook them, hurry, hurry.
Shure: 勾人快快
Shure: Hook them quickly.
Shure: 你不急吗勾
Shure: Aren't you in a hurry? Hook.
其他人：开板已经开板
Others: The board is open.
Shure: 我好急
Shure: I'm so anxious.
其他人：我采访一下你以前吃的非常舒
Others: Let me interview you, you used to be very comfortable.
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome.
Alice:逐渐同化
Alice: Gradually assimilating
Jake:你回头你回头再测一下哈哈哈
Jake: Check it again later, haha
Shure: 你今天晚上测一下
Shure: Test it tonight
Shure: 啊我们今天
Shure: Ah, today we...
Jake:哈哈哈屁人训练计划哈哈哈
Jake: Haha, poop training plan, hahaha
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Shure: 把那个投投个屏开始给你测一下
Shure: Project it on the screen, let's test it
其他人：哈
Others: Haha
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome
Shure: 公开处刑
Shure: Public execution
其他人：他这个眼睛咋了
Others: What's wrong with his eyes?
Jake:我试试
Jake: Let me try
Jake:哦他这个没开确实没开
Jake: Oh, it's not on, it really isn't on
Jake:然后这个肯定是没插
Jake: And this is definitely not plugged in
Jake:这个是要不就
Jake: This one is either...
其他人:插好了
Others: It's plugged in
Jake:有电但是没开
Jake: There's power but it's not on
Shure: 你要找币
Shure: Do you need to find the coin?
Jake:开了就他显然没充电
Jake: If it's on, it clearly didn't charge
Jake:我靠这100%开玩笑
Jake: Damn, this is 100% a joke
Jake:就是就是他没开
Jake: It's just not on
Shure: 你先把币找着行
Shure: You find the coin first
Jake:他有电但是没开
Jake: It has power but it's not on
Jake:嗯这咋不开啊
Jake: Hmm, why isn't it turning on?
其他人:那没电了呀
Others: It ran out of power
Alice:嗯那个热水可以递给我一下吗
Alice: Um, can you pass me the hot water?
Jake:他得一直闪着
Jake: It should keep flashing
Jake:他在这有电
Jake: It's got power here
Jake:开机了是吧
Jake: It's on, right?
Jake:开机了不是不是什么手机
Jake: It's on, it's not a phone
Alice:啊谢谢
Alice: Ah, thanks
Tasha: 200克就行
Tasha: 200 grams is enough
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh dear
Jake:插了呀他要有电
Jake: It's plugged in, it should have power
Alice:嗯好
Alice: Okay
其他人:充电宝充电宝有电OK
Others: The power bank has power, okay
Jake:充电宝有电
Jake: The power bank has power
Jake:但是你开着的时候它在充电
Jake: But when it's on, it should be charging
Jake:它刚刚没有显示就没有电
Jake: It didn't show, so there's no power
Shure: 哎你不用你先找币
Shure: Hey, you don't need to, just find the coin first
Jake:就是没没有在供电
Jake: There's no power supply.
Shure: 你的计划没有用
Shure: Your plan is useless.
Shure: 你把币给我找着
Shure: Find the coin for me.
Jake:就这个意思
Jake: That's what I mean.
Tasha: 上哥现在就再来铺一层
Tasha: Let's put another layer on top now.
Jake:现在就
Jake: Right now.
Tasha: 嗯没了
Tasha: Yeah, that's all.
Lucia: 这是您刚才擦过的吗
Lucia: Did you just wipe this?
Lucia: 那放的那个
Lucia: The one you placed there.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:用手快一点吧
Alice: Use your hands to be quicker.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Tasha: 上哥再铺一层
Tasha: Let's put another layer on top.
其他人：没了
Others: No more.
Alice:那边还有一包呢
Alice: There's another bag over there.
Jake:这个就是在充电
Jake: This is charging.
Jake:给它充一会吧
Jake: Let it charge for a while.
Tasha:  买的居然刚刚好
Tasha: We bought just the right amount.
其他人:对对
Others: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 一般就是要铺两层
Tasha: Usually, we need to put two layers.
其他人:我觉得
Others: I think...
其他人:不然不如你直接把这个都搁里边
Others: Or you can just put all of this inside.
其他人::然后把这个稍微放里边
Others: And then put this inside a bit.
Tasha: 不行
Tasha: No, that won't work.
Alice:那样会把底下的底给破坏了
Alice: That way, you'll damage the bottom.
其他人:搞这么专业
Others: Doing it so professionally.
其他人:这是专业脚
Others: This is professional stuff.
其他人:别学到这个是哪里
Others: Where did you learn this?
Lucia: 这还有两根耶
Lucia: There are two more here.
Tasha: 这俩别浪费
Tasha: Don't waste these two.
其他人:这是干嘛的茶
Others: What's this tea for?
其他人：茶
Others: Tea.
Alice:直接用手吧
Alice: Just use your hands.
Alice:你那个你那个有底
Alice: That one, you have a base.
Alice:我放
Alice: I'll put it.
Lucia: 提拉米苏
Lucia: Tiramisu.
其他人：为什么为什么这样
Others: Why, why like this?
Tasha: 哎你别搞这么快
Tasha: Hey, don't do it so quickly.
其他人:为什么你这样子搞这么快啊
Others: Why are you doing it so fast?
Shure: 怎么屡教不改呢刘帅
Shure: Why don't you ever learn, Choiszt?
Lucia: 就是做底
Lucia: Just laying the foundation.
Jake:怎么还在放了
Jake: Why is it still playing?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
其他人:等会再放等会再放
Others: Wait a bit, wait a bit.
其他人：啊啊啊完了拍拍会拍会要跳起来
Others: Ahh, it's over. Snap, snap, it's about to jump.
其他人：你别搁这
Others: Don't stay here.
其他人:因为我感觉他真的已经非常重要
Others: Because I feel it's really important.
Jake:好换一个换一个
Jake: Okay, switch it, switch it.
其他人:你等他
Others: Wait for him.
其他人:你等他摆完你再放你等他摆完你再放
Others: Wait for him to finish, then you do it. Wait for him to finish, then you do it.
其他人:我知道我知道
Others: I know, I know.
其他人：我知道我知道
Jake:你知道个球
Jake: You know nothing.
Jake:你知道哈哈哈
Jake: You know, haha.
其他人:好好的我错了但是我下次继续
Others: Alright, alright. I was wrong, but I'll continue next time.
其他人:心里有数心里有数心里有数
Others: Got it, got it, got it.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
其他人:哈哈哈来
Others: Hahaha, come on.
其他人:那怎么就多一层啊
Others: Why is there an extra layer?
Alice:没事无妨
Alice: It's fine, no problem.
其他人：这不是你
Others: It's not you.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
其他人：多吃一口多好
Others: Eat one more bite, it's great.
Jake:这是尖眼你知道吧
Jake: This is sharp, you know.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人:哈就不能让你多吃一口
Others: Hah, can't let you eat one more bite.
其他人:不行这个ESP真的不
Others: No, this ESP really isn't...
其他人:这这这叫什么人格
Others: What is this personality?
Alice:荣格荣格巴维
Alice: It's Jung's theory.
其他人:芭蕾说的非常的不准
Others: Ballet's explanation is very inaccurate.
其他人:里面可能是人在骗你了
Others: Maybe someone inside is deceiving you.
其他人:啥意思没事
Others: What do you mean, it's fine.
其他人：啥意思没事
Lucia: 就是那个MBTI
Lucia: It's the MBTI.
Lucia: 他原本是荣格巴韦理论然后脱胎的
Lucia: It was originally based on Jung's theory.
Lucia: 一个一个人格模型测试
Lucia: It's a personality model test.
其他人：其实这包这包感觉开的有点浪
Others: Actually, this pack feels a bit wasteful.
其他人:这这一层是平这波
Others: This layer is just flat, this wave...
其他人:这波无法
Others: This wave is impossible.
Alice:无妨
Tasha: 开
其他人：但是要浪费
Others: But it'll be a waste.
Alice:没事你剩下你可以吃
Tasha: 然后现场就吃掉
Tasha: Then we can eat it on the spot.
Tasha: 现场就吃
Tasha: Eat it on the spot.
其他人:哎这其实也可以塞下是吧
Others: Hey, actually we can fit this, right?
其他人:就其他的啊
Others: Just the other stuff.
Tasha: 嗯现场就吃
Tasha: Yeah, eat it on the spot.
Jake:吃
Jake: Eat.
Tasha: 你准备几个小托盘
Tasha: You prepare a few small trays.
Tasha: 咱们现场吃掉它好吃吗
Tasha: Let's eat it on the spot, is it tasty?
其他人:所以这个蛋挞是我们自己开的书吗
Others: So are these egg tarts from our own book?
其他人:还是买好的书
Others: Or a bought book?
其他人:买好的那个
Others: The bought one.
其他人:哦
Others: Oh.
Jake:我们的b呢
Jake: Where's our B?
Jake:我们的b啊
Jake: Our B, huh?
Jake:可能在这里面
Jake: Maybe it's in here.
Lucia: 哎我今天早上还看见他了
Lucia: Hey, I saw it this morning.
Jake:b在哪啊
Jake: Where's B?
Jake:你知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Tasha: 吃吧吃吧
Tasha: Eat, eat.
Lucia: 在那吗不在
Lucia: Is it there? No.
Tasha: 这个哎
Tasha: This one, hey.
Tasha: 好吧最后一个还剩几个
Tasha: Okay, how many are left?
Tasha: 我们吃掉
Tasha: Let's eat them.
其他人:还有6 还有8个啊
Others: There are still 6, 8 left.
其他人:6个哎这还有7个
Others: 6, hey there are still 7.
Shure: 世界总有人在忙忙碌碌寻宝藏
Shure: People around the world are always busy searching for treasures.
Shure: 快找币
Shure: Quick, find the B.
其他人:什么东西
Others: What?
Jake:b
Jake: B.
Lucia: 我们的那个最后一天
Lucia: Our last day with that.
Jake:您您知道吗
Jake: Do you know?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
其他人:没币
Others: No B.
Lucia: 作为通货的那个贴纸
Lucia: The stickers we used as currency.
Jake:不知道没
Jake: Don't know, no?
Jake:b在哪
Jake: Where's B?
Tasha: 我记得在这
Tasha: I remember it's here.
Tasha: 桌子上
Tasha: On the table.
Jake:好嘞哪个桌子上
Jake: Okay, which table is it on?
Tasha: 就在这个桌子上
Tasha: It's on this table.
Jake:这个桌子上好
Jake: This table, okay.
其他人:b吗
Others: Is it B?
Lucia: 咱还有更多的桌子吗
Lucia: Do we have more tables?
其他人:我看看b长什么样
Others: Let me see what B looks like.
Shure: 就是贴纸是吗
Shure: It's the sticker, right?
Jake:你现在很难知道我长什么样
Jake: It's hard for you to know what I look like right now.
Alice:我也想知道长啥样
Alice: I also want to know what it looks like.
Tasha: 好无语的样子
Tasha: This is so frustrating.
其他人:这是b吗
Others: Is this B?
Tasha: 这是贴画呀啊
Tasha: This is a sticker.
Alice:贴画呀呃不是这个
Alice: A sticker, huh? Not this one.
Tasha: 呃不是这个贴画吗
Tasha: Huh? Not this sticker?
Lucia: 不是可
Lucia: No, it's not.
其他人:这不是币吗
Others: Isn't this a token?
Jake:不是不是不是不是
Jake: No, no, no, no.
其他人:不是b
Others: It's not B.
Jake:b是圆的
Jake: B is round.
Jake:圆圆的圆的
Jake: Round, round.
Jake:贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸贴纸
Jake: Sticker, sticker, sticker, sticker, sticker.
其他人：贴纸确实藏挺好
Others: The sticker is really well hidden.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我们自己都找不见了
Lucia: Haha, we can't even find it ourselves.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 对对对已经藏好了
Lucia: Right, right, it's already hidden.
其他人:能藏在哪啊
Others: Where can it be hidden?
Lucia: 现在是bond环节就大家一起找哈哈哈
Lucia: Now it's the bond segment, everyone looks for it together, hahaha.
Shure: 找到了找到币了
Shure: Found it, found the token.
Alice:OK完美
Alice: OK, perfect.
其他人:找到币了
Others: Found the token.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎上面的桌子上啊原来是
Lucia: Ah, it was on top of the table.
Shure: 就是贴纸
Shure: It's the sticker.
其他人：哦高级的
Others: Oh, fancy.
其他人：我知道藏哪
Others: I know where it's hidden.
Shure: 藏到你的
Shure: Hidden in your...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:我的天哪
Alice: Oh my god.
其他人:是不是这个
其他人:就是这个
其他人: 不是就是这个
Jake:哈哈哈
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈怎么回事
Jake:什么意思啊
Lucia: 猛男脱衣舞
Jake:啊哦哦哦
Lucia: 能当啊可以可以当
Jake:啊可以可以当币
Shure: 但是我们就有假币
Jake:这个算
Shure: 这是良币
Lucia: 隐藏款
Jake:这这算一分的吧
Jake:就那是一块的吧
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: 警惕劣币驱逐良币
Shure: Beware of bad money driving out good money.
其他人：劣币驱逐两币
Others: Bad money drives out good money.
Alice:这只有16多了
Alice: This only has 16 left.
Shure: 这有150个吗
Shure: Are there 150 of these?
Lucia: 有吧一包50个
Lucia: Should be, each pack has 50.
Alice:内存哎
Alice: Memory, hey.
Alice:不储存 1616够 16 够
Alice: No need to store, 16 is enough, 16 is enough.
Jake:16够 16 够
Jake: 16 is enough, 16 is enough.
Alice:如果他没存储了自己断了
Alice: If it doesn't store, it'll just stop on its own.
Alice:他应该是会存着吧
Alice: It should store, right?
Jake:啊对会存会存
Jake: Yeah, it'll store, it'll store.
Alice:哦那就好
Alice: Oh, that's good then.
Lucia: 见不得人
Lucia: Embarrassing.
Lucia: 你是笑话我
Lucia: Are you making fun of me?
Lucia: 你来藏自己房间吗
Lucia: Are you hiding in your room?
Jake:来
Jake: No.
Jake:不用藏房间
Jake: No need to hide in the room.
Lucia: 主要是藏房间的话
Lucia: But if you hide in the room...
Jake:不藏房间就在外边
Jake: No hiding in the room, just stay outside.
Lucia: 啊那就好
Lucia: Ah, that's good then.
Lucia: 要不然行李没地放
Lucia: Otherwise, there won't be space for luggage.
Alice:藏那上面呗
Alice: Just hide it up there.
Jake:不能让他们爬不能让他们碰到相机
Jake: Don't let them climb, don't let them touch the camera.
Lucia: 难度是不是太高了哈哈哈
Lucia: Isn't this too difficult? Hahaha.
Jake:燕子可以不能爬相机
Jake: Swallows can, but they can't climb on the camera.
Alice:不能藏相机
Alice: Don't hide the camera.
Alice:能藏这里面
Alice: We can hide it in here.
Jake:我去哈
Jake: I'll go check.
Alice:哎这怎么连个拉锁都没有
Alice: Hey, why doesn't this even have a zipper?
Shure: 他连屁股都没有
Shure: It doesn't even have a bottom.
Shure: 我们还没藏呢
Shure: We haven't hidden it yet.
Jake:哈哈我们找到了
Jake: Haha, we found it!
Shure: 你找找你再找
Shure: You keep looking, keep looking.
Jake:藏这了藏这了
Jake: It's hidden here, hidden here.
其他人：这有50吗
Others: Is there 50 here?
其他人：妈的又没骗150
Others: Damn, didn't we cheat 150?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:150 我们匀个50来藏还是多少来藏
Jake: 150, let's hide 50, or how much should we hide?
Jake:2020 藏20吧
Jake: 2020, let's hide 20.
Shure: 2020
Shure: 2020.
其他人：20很难藏
Others: 20 is hard to hide.
其他人：就这么大
Others: It's this big.
Jake:藏
Jake: Hide it.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
其他人：能藏在每个人房间
Others: Can we hide it in everyone's room?
Alice:藏这吗
Alice: Hide it here?
Jake:二十吧
Jake: Twenty, right?
Alice:就这底下
Alice: Just under here.
Katrina: 那让嘉宾往下爬
Katrina: Then let the guests climb down.
Alice:他不一定
Alice: He might not.
Alice:他不一定会爬呀
Alice: He might not climb.
Jake:藏他二十个哈
Jake: Hide his twenty.
其他人:是不是ECO friend
Others: Is it ECO friendly?
其他人:我以为是environmental friend
Others: I thought it was environmental friend.
Shure: 不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Jake:是都可以都可以都可以
Jake: It can be both, it can be both.
Shure: 可能他要打把e后局吧
Shure: Maybe he wants to play an E game.
Jake:能冲进去
Jake: Can you rush in?
刚好20个
Just twenty.
Alice:这每个都长不一样吗
Alice: Are they all different?
Katrina: 嗯应该是
Katrina: Yeah, I think so.
Alice:是多少组啊
Alice: How many groups are there?
Katrina: 三组每组50个
Katrina: Three sets, each with 50.
Katrina: 然后我们20个吧
Katrina: And then we do 20.
Tasha: 干嘛
Tasha: What for?
Jake:拿我的哼
Jake: Take mine, hmph.
Tasha: 你不相信我的数据线
Tasha: You don't trust my cable?
Jake:不不相信你的充电宝
Jake: No, I don't trust your power bank.
Jake:相信我的充电宝
Jake: Trust my power bank.
Lucia: 好的
Lucia: Okay.
Jake:藏吧
Jake: Hide it.
Lucia: 感觉我藏完明天就忘了自己藏哪了
Lucia: I feel like I'll forget where I hid it by tomorrow.
Jake:你试试
Jake: Give it a try.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Great, great, great.
Lucia: 哎你放在哪里了
Lucia: Hey, where did you put it?
Lucia: 哦哎很棒
Lucia: Oh, awesome.
Jake:大对大伙藏
Jake: Hide it for everyone.
Jake:然后给我们
Jake: And then give it to us.
Jake:就我们内部先知道一下好吧
Jake: Just let us know internally first, okay?
Lucia: 估计内部明天就忘了
Lucia: We'll probably forget by tomorrow.
Jake:对对对不然自己都不记得了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, or else we won't remember ourselves.
Lucia: 海盗船长忘记了宝藏在哪里全剧终
Lucia: The pirate captain forgot where the treasure was, end of story.
Shure: 看我藏那了
Shure: Look where I hid it.
Shure: 是不是不易被发现
Shure: Isn't it hard to find?
Alice:哎等一下
Alice: Hey, wait a sec.
Jake:哪哪啊你藏哪了
Jake: Where? Where did you hide it?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 牛吧
Shure: Cool, huh?
Jake:牛
Jake: Yeah, cool.
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Alice:你别动
Alice: Don't move.
Jake:那给我一个我也要藏
Jake: Give me one, I want to hide too.
Alice:我也要这能藏藏
Alice: I want to hide this too.
Jake:藏藏人头上是吧
Jake: Hide it on top of someone's head, right?
Jake:我觉得可以藏藏头里藏里掐掐
Jake: I think we can hide it in the hair, hide it and pinch it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我这头发能
Shure: My hair can...
Katrina: 鸡窝头
Katrina: Like a bird's nest.
Shure: 能藏藏20个是吧
Shure: Can hide 20, right?
Lucia: 放书架上
Lucia: Put it on the bookshelf.
Shure: 谁给老子发消息了
Shure: Who texted me?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:哎呀找一个瘦一点的
Alice: Oh no, find a slimmer one.
Shure: 你看我那就很不明显
Shure: Look at mine, it's really not obvious.
Alice:哎呀又掉
其他人:很明显了
Others: It's very obvious.
其他人:我藏了一个
Others: I hid one.
Jake:你藏哪去了
Jake: Where did you hide it?
Jake:哪啊
Jake: Where?
其他人:那
Others: There.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 你怎么
Tasha: How did you...
Tasha: 被你发现了
Tasha: How did you find it?
Jake:哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Oh, sorry, sorry.
Shure: 不好找你就不
Shure: If you can't find it, then...
Jake:哈哈哈没有没有不好意思不好意思
Jake: Hahaha, no, no, sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:我以为这是个桌子
Jake: I thought it was a table.
Jake:哈哈不好意思
Jake: Haha, sorry.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:这在哪在哪啊在
Jake: Where is it, where is it?
其他人:我告诉你都找不着
Others: I'm telling you, you won't find it.
Jake:哪
Jake: Where?
其他人:那那就完蛋了
Others: There, it's over.
Alice:藏这吧
Jake:我靠这你确实
Jake: Oh man, you really...
Jake:确实我真以为是个桌子
Jake: Really, I thought it was a table.
Tasha: 这个位置要藏几个啊
Tasha: How many can we hide here?
Jake:因为原来这有个桌子
Jake: Because there used to be a table here.
Tasha: 这个人已经藏了一个了
Tasha: This person already hid one.
Lucia: 那是已经藏了一个的吗
Lucia: Did they already hide one?
其他人:藏在这个里面能看到吗
Others: Can you see it if you hide it in here?
Lucia: 好吧哎
Lucia: Okay then.
Lucia: 这不好像不是这是标签
Lucia: This doesn't seem right, this is a tag.
其他人:哎呦我靠
Others: Oh my god.
Alice:哎呦我靠放底下啊
Alice: Oh my god, put it underneath.
其他人:真看不到你怎么拿出来
Others: You really can't see it, how did you get it out?
Shure: 你怎么拿出来
Shure: How did you get it out?
Alice:这是贴的
Alice: It's stuck on.
Shure: 我想问你
Shure: I want to ask you...
Jake:对对对这个破坏道具了
Jake: Yeah, yeah, this damaged the prop.
其他人:不都全傻的吗
Others: Aren't they all dumb anyway?
Jake:哎不对不行
Jake: Hey, no, that's not right.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Jake:哈哈哈这是一个隐藏爆款发现结果
Jake: Hahaha, this is a hidden gem discovery.
Shure: 哦这里
Shure: Oh, over here.
Tasha: 这是一个隐藏爆款
Tasha: This is a hidden gem.
其他人:我靠确实
Others: Wow, it really is.
Jake:这又是哪啊
Jake: Where is this place?
Jake:哈哈哈哦这个你一遍
Jake: Hahaha, oh, this one, try it.
其他人:可以直接藏厕所垃圾桶塞
Others: You can hide it in the bathroom trash can.
其他人：你得塞怕你拿不出来
Others: You have to stuff it in, or you can't get it out.
Jake:哈哈你拿倒
Jake: Haha, you can take it out.